[Applaudissements]
allez et bien mes enfants alors
maintenant il y a presque toute la
troupe alors là c'est vraiment le
Châtelet c'est les trois mousquetaires
bah mes enfants il y a du monde autant
en profiter oh ben oui alors là cette
situation est très intéressante elle est
fédolienne dans Jol ah les féolire dans
le boudoir d'une cocotte 1900 ah il y a
du costume oui oui un père tombe il
tombe né à
nez avec son fils c'est qui va le faire
c'est
on a la chute oh oui on lui dit toujours
bah tiens vous tombez bien vous pour ça
qu'on l'engage et le valet de chambre
tentera d'arranger les choses voilà
alors le père sera Roger Carel tu avais
deviné le valallet de chambre sera Jan
la cocotte jeanpoiret
oui la cocotte minute
alors non le fils Jean Poiret la cocotte
Sophie desmaré alors là vous avez une
phrase direelle faut bien la prendre B
oui vraiment vous allez faire pleur le
la phrase à dire dans les dernières 20
secondes sera quand vous dansiez dans ce
temps-là pas besoin de wawawa
quand vous dansiez qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire P la chanson Nicolas PAC la
waa c'est la ceux qui vont sur
les les guitar un peu fait quand vousiez
dans
ce et ben je m'arrangerai pour pas la
dire c allez plein sa ça c'est l'écolier
1900 en B ça va c'est vraiment du B oui
mais moi- ce que ça ça c'est pas très
dis pardon il pas un bo non non ça ça
fait tout à
fait ça suffit si je me mettais une
décoration oh là il faut une CAN mes
enfants à et tu dois te mettre une
décoration non oui tu as raison
tiens bon ben mes enfants on a assez
bavardé l'émission est terminée alors ça
va on peut les bagues on a passé l'heure
non allez on y va qu'est-ce que tu fais
comm oh là là qu'elle fait comm
comm c'est drôle parce que on pourrait
penser que c'est toi je suis chez moi
allez faittoi je suis avec mon attention
je fais les trois coups mes enfants vous
êtes prêts
attention
Firma madame qui qui doit venir
maintenant à qui le tour ben vous savez
il y en a tellement
c'est Monsieur que je me rappelle plus
son nom je me souvis plus de son nom
mais j'attends ah attendez je vais
prendre mon planning c'est ça oui
madame voilà et je vais me préparer mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fa ils sont en retard
sûrment madame ah voilà je je fais je je
vais ouvrir madame oui c'est bon trè
bien c'est absurde d'IR re mes
chaussures
monsieur excusez-moi monieur
mademoiselle mademoiselle émilianne gros
cheval oui elle est elle est elle est là
c'est ici si vous voulez vous asseoir TR
bien elle m'attends oui oh c'est
Monsieur groscheval non non c'est Madame
groscheval ah très bien très bien moi
c'est Monsieur baudruffin Edgar baruffin
monsieur quelle joie de vous voir
bonjour madame aucheval vous attends
avec impatience oh écoutez je rêvais de
ça depuis longtemps oh écoutez depuis
euh depuis pratiquement 40 ans
maintenant oh c'était hier pas changé je
n'ai jamais connu de femme madame vous
êtes ma première je vous ai tellement je
vous ai tellement admiré quand vous
étiez au théâtre je voyais toujours papa
papa m'emmenit tout le temps de papa de
papa l'emmenit vous voir on vous a vu
depuis des générations madame alors mon
rêve c'était de vous approcher d'être
près de vous on me disait toujours oh il
faut avoir vu Émilienne gros cheval dans
Natalie était très bonne par la création
par la création bien sûr mais plus tard
plus tard on me disait oh Émilienne gros
cheval oh oh le charme oh et vous n'êtes
pas déçu oh pas du tout madame bienvenez
vous ne serez pas du vous êtes presque
aussi bien de près que de loin plutôt
mieux faut dire que j'étais très loin au
fauteil d'orchestre nousavions pas
beaucoup d'argent avec Papa bon madame
qu'est-ce que je fais je reste vous
pouvez avec nous ah non je je sors par
oh
votre n oh faites pas l'impécine vous me
voyez trois fois par semaine Émilien mon
gros madame madame madame il y a un
monsieur là qui veut vous voir Émilienne
mon gros dad chez moi ton petit
jquetise
découvre je je suis arrivé jetais embêté
ma chérie oh mon trésor j'ai vu devant
la porte la voiture est les chevaux de
mon fils oh ça n'est rien il doit êre
dans le quartier sur quoi je fais pardon
excusez-mo j'ai vu il doit faire
quelques cours dans le qutier je ne
voudrais pas pardon je vous n'ai pas
peur il écoute toujours ce qu'on dit
comme non pas du tout je voudrais pas le
rencontrer parce que malheureux je
savait que son papa
ilen'était très imprudent à devenenir
comme ça avec tes tincorass tes
décorations le visage à
découvert flat
toujours beauienne vous venez men je
m'ennuie tout seul oui mon ami attendez
une minute qui est là non non c'est non
non c'est rien c'est rien comment c'est
rien j'ai cononnaî la voix de mon fils
non pas du tout non non non non non non
non non non
mais il me reconnaî tout le temps M non
papa m'a reconnu àvec père et le fils
c'est papa quelle joie moi qui Réville
une vie de famille une vie de famille
mais c'est déjà une vie de famille oh oh
mon petit garçon papa dans ce tempsl on
avait pas besoin de guitare wa oui elle
sait plus du tout ce que c'est ça c'est
pas une guitare c'est quoi quand vous
dans cher dans ce temp mon pantalon vous
n'aviez plus besoin de
pédal je suis au
courant vous avez réuni